M - Okay, ready? Let's do this
T - Were you doing an intro to a porn-
*upbeat music*
*disapproval*
*slight smile*
T - Hah! You blinked
M - I can see everything
A - No one wants that
M - Kathryn I can see EVVVERYTHING
*Warfstache babbles beautifully*
W - Hunting Soviets before they were Soviets
*continues to babble*
W - Kill them while they're young, I say
*more wonderful babbling*
W - Youngest Pharaoh in the Egyptian armies!
*infinite babbling*
W - Know the guy named Moses? Oh it's me!
*final words of babble*
*le stretch*
*le point*
M - Uhhh I'm King of the Squirrels
M - Hi. I'm King of the Squirrels.
M - I uhh.. I'm king of the Squirrels
M - Don't mind us. Weird; I know this looks weird
M - Don't worry about it
- Alright
*laughter from behind the cameras*
M - This is your ball
M - This is your ball on drugs
M - Any questions?
M - That went way faster than I thought it was gonna go
*all laugh*
M - Did that hit you in the face?
- Yeah!
M - Oh Jesus!
M - It was like, I flicked my wrist and it went flying!
M - I'm sorry. It can never work between us
*bushes rustle*
*laughter behind the camera*
*fits of laughter off-camera*
M - Are you suffering from chronic unfunny syndrome when you have no ideas left
to put in your stupid bullshit Markiplier TV sketch?
M-  Fucking god dang it (laughter from everyone)
M - Ah, I seem to be stuck on my hands
M - If you are like me and have nothing funny left, just go watch other YouTubers and steal from them
M - And then you'll have a whole truck full of funny stuff and you'll never run out
because everyone's more creative than you anyway so why even bother trying?
M - Side affects may include:
M - Repressed nightmares
M - Constant inferiority complex
M - Low self-esteem
M - A complete loss of bowel function
M - Uhh, you might have explosive toenails
M - Oh. Hello, don't mind me
*laughter*
*prolonged yawn*
M - Was that funny?
A - It wasn't very funny.
M - *whispers something he shouldn't be saying*
*laughter*
M -Woahh! Hey! What, no! Please, I don't wanna...
*off-camera laughter*
M - Uhh! Agh! Eyy!
*laughter*
M - Alright what else can we do?
M - Amy, any ideas?
M - You're dying!
M - Marzipan
M - Dying!
*cat meow*
M - I'm sorry
M - You're dying
M - I know it's hard to accept but you can't run away
M - Chica. I'm sorry
M - You're dying
T - Awww shiiiit
*laughter*
A - Aww shiiiit
E - You can't do this to me!
E - I hate myself so much
W - So I stabbed him, I stabbed him and I stabbed him
W - And I was laughing and he was laughing and he just died
E - Yeah I think that would be considered a sin
W - Are you out of your goddamn mind?
W - How many drugs are you on right now?
E - Don't use the Lord's name in vain
W - Oh fuck God and-
W - You know, I just feel like I'm a little misguided here
W - There seems to be all these misunderstandings where people just end up
dying around me for various random reasons
E - Maybe you need to find the Lord?
W - Am I cursed Father?
E - Maybe you're cursed
W - Where are you from?
W- Where-?
E - Maybe these are cursed?
W - Don't touch me, where the frick are you from?
W - What's your accent?
E - *while laughing* I don't know
*chirpy happy music*
*birds chirp peacefully in the background*
M - Hello one or two people
M - My name is Markiplier and I'm back with another episode of Subnautica
M - Tomorrow I'll be playing Happy Wheels
M - Let's get into it... I died
M - I really hope you haven't gotten my keyboard because there's a fucking nail right there
M - Have you gotten any of my keyboard there?
E - No
M - Oh fuck, I bet you have
*Ethan laughs*
*more laughter*
M - *sobbing* BWEHBWEHBWEHBWEHBWEH
BWEHBWEHBWEHBWEHBWEHBWEHBWEH
BWEHBWEHBWEHEHEHBWEHBWEH
E - Doo doo doo doo doo doo
A - Oh I don't know!
A - Open, fucking here I go!
*laughter*
M - Bah nah mee mah dee bah mo
M - Mah bo bo
M - Shuma dee bah mee dah
*gibberish*
M - It da- *bursts out laughing*
E - You wanna talk about your stick?
M - Ahh yeah, I just found this stick
M - I think it's plus 2 to bear slaying
M - It's pretty aerodynamic, like if you get a good whippage to it I think it's sturdy as can be
M - It's a good bloodletting stick, you just *imitates stab sound* and then the blood drains out so
M - I don't know, it's got some heft to it, it's perfectly balanced as you can see
M - It's perfectly balanced
M - 100% authentic wood
M - Yeah. Do you like that?
E - Yeah
M - You like that? Do you like that?
M - Where'd it go?
M - Here. It was in my hand the whole time
E - Woah. It always comes back to you?
M - Fool. Oh yeah, watch this
M - Right back to me
M - Hang on wait, go to Australia
M - Oh g'day mate! It's back, bitch *ksssssh*
E - Hi Tyler
T - Hello
T - I am... on my knees
E - Getting ready to suck that dick huehuehue
*door slam*
M - Tyler can you go get a Clorox wipe?
T - Yeah
M - She might've had a little dribble dribble on the driver's seat
T - Drool or pee?
M - Oh you know which one
M - But only if you help
M - Just by clicking that button down there, you can make a difference in one man with way too big of an ego
M - You can make his head just swell a little bit larger
M - And his heart will be exactly the same
M - In light of YouTube's restrictive ad policy,
we will be completely family-friendly from now on
M - Words like fuck and shit and cunt
will be replaced with family-friendly alternatives
like fudge, and shooters, and cunt
*laughter*
M - Do you want smaller YouTubers like CrankGameplays, JackSepticEye,
OGChanYT growing out of nowhere and replacing the wonderful Markiplier? No.
M - I don't even know who they are
M - Get out, get out of here
M - Get, get, get, shoo
fuck off
M - If you don't help subscribe to Markiplier, he's going to have to shut down his other channels
that you may know as Shoenice, Keemstar, OGChanYT, Girbeagly
M - They're all him
M - They're all me
M - I am everyone
M - PewDiePie, that's not me
M - The aliens have probed peacefully
M - And now for the weather, Jim?
M - And all of the badgers thankfully died
M - And Arnold Schwarzenegger's last words were: "Hasta LaVista, I cheated on my wife"
M - And now for the weather, Jim?
M - And so that's how rabies became the new weight-loss sensation that swept the nation
M - And I believe that the storm should pass, millions have died thus far
M - We're having a good time out here
M - Jim?
M - Thanks Jim, we're really in a scramble out here, it's currently raining cats and dogs and I-
M - Thanks Jim, as you can see we made it to, what I can only assume is the middle of the ocean
M - I don't know how I got here. Jim?
M - BUBBLE BUBBLE BUBBLE
M - BUBBLES!
M - BUBBLEEEES!!
M - BUBBBBLES
*underwater mouth sounds*
M - All glory to the Hypnotoad
M - And BUBBLES!!
M - Shimbaaaaa mee noooooo
M - Him babaaa fabooooo shibidibado
M - Ee bah bum
M - OOOOoOOOoOOOoOoooOOOOOOo
M - I can do that
M - Chikadika boop boop
M - Doop bee mah nah mo doo
M - Bee bah, nuuuh bah
M - Eh do mah mee feh
M - Ee doh mah nee dwaa
M - It donna bee dwa
M - It donna be DWAAA
M - BEE MOHH
- Doo bah dee
W - It's gonna be Mayyy
W - IT'S gonna be Mayyy
W - It's gonna be MAYYY
W - It's gonna be May!
W - It's gonna be May!!
W - It's gonna be May
W - It's gonna be Mayyyy
E - And that's the end
M - That's the end
E - Any closing thoughts?
M - Er, I'm the King of the Squirrels